je pense que dans la communication on
n'est pas bons on voit bien que la
l'idée du gouvernement est que cette
campagne de vaccination puisse rattraper
l'épidémie mais aujourd'hui c'était
faire abstraction de tous et de ces
choses qu'on ne contrôle pas
c'est-à-dire l'approvisionnement du
vaccin de la part des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques c'est-à-dire l'émergence
de nouveaux variants c'est-à-dire
l'acceptation de la population et tout
ça on a là on parle de demi-mesure de
sur mesure de haute couture surtout
l'impression qu'on avance à tâtons et
que on essaye de tenir jusqu'au bout
mais métier qu'est ce que c'est que le
bout finalement vous dire des gens en
ont marre il faut par confiner et est ce
que les gens n'ont pas assez justement
des demi mesures ou finalement ils ont
pas le droit de faire comme d'habitude
mais en même temps c'est pas
complètement fermé non plus donc on this
ce temps long sur ces deux mesures qui
me semble est très important sur le côté
lassitude alors que en février on aurait
eu une fenêtre de confinement plus dur
est peut-être difficile avec les pieds
sur le moment mais on serait pas dans la
situation que l'on est aujourd'hui
[Musique]